it'll be dame dunning this afternoon for
the rangers it'll be his 14th start of
the season era just north of four and a
half
and a base hit to left and arize extends
that short hitting streak with his first
swing a lead off single here in the
first horizon first here's byron buxton
and a high fly to deep left field
martin going back
and buckston with his first home run
since his return into the upper deck and
it's two to nothing byron boxed in with
a two-round home run and the twins out
to an early lead four consecutive hits
to start the day here for the twins and
now the number five batter digs in the
left-handed hitting alex kiriloff starts
we get to come back he'll go to second
for one on the first double play and
there's a gift
that's a pitcher's best friend you can
understand why and it's even better
when he gets it right back to him as he
just did so two men out now will run
over third for polanco here's a swing
and a miss
by polanco on that sinker from dunning
and so dane will escape the inning with
minimal damage considering right-hander
kenta maid a second start since he has
come off the injured list making his
11th start so with two out of nobody on
he takes on the nolis garcia and this
one is down the third baseline and then
off that fence into an odd spot and
garcia will have an easy two out double
an eight pitch watch for gallow the
rangers have a couple of base runners
with nick solac coming up swung on a
misty struck him out maeda fans solac
leaves a pair and we're through one in
texas kepler on board with the lead off
walk and brings up ben rortvet pitch on
the way ground ball hit to solac he
pivots goes to second for one on the
first double play that's four six three
but it's a counter for lefo who turns it
and that's it two innings and two double
plays for dan dyn now on the corners
with two hours buxton clobber a hanging
breaking ball for a two-run home run in
the first
here's a ball bounce to the right side
so like a long run to his left up with
it the throw to first just in time
nice play by nick solak getting over to
that slow bouncer to retire buxton so
lonnick throwing the bases cruz the
hitter o2 pitch and he strikes out
swinging away some nifty work there from
dame dunning nelson cruz obviously not
seeing this pitch very well at all from
dane dunning he missed that by a lot off
the hitter swinging him as he gets carol
off chasing a pitch that wasn't in the
zone a sinker wide of the plate but back
to back strikeouts for dane dunning the
way kiriloff swung you so late it
appeared as if dunny just blew it right
by him second walk issued by dunning the
twins would do well to take advantage of
this here kepler with two on and two out
swung on hit sharply base hit max kepler
the lead runner will round and larnick's
headed for home and gallo runs right
over the top of the ball polanco will
score as well kepler's into second base
the dam has opened a little and it's
four-nothing minnesota twins gallow ran
right over the top of that baseball that
let polanco score and it let kepler get
into scoring position as we go to the
bottom of the third kentucky with a four
nothing lead here's jose trevino as the
3-2 swung out of this tomato gets your
second strikeout you see a good slider
from maya there starts that ball in the
strike zone and breaks down below and
with two outs rodolis garcia is the
battery swings and misses and he struck
him out maeda began the inning with a
strikeout and he ends the inning with
the strikeout his third of the ball game
we've played three the rise at first
base credited for his third hit and
that'll bring up byron bunkston
buxton scalding one fair into the left
field corner arrives rounding second on
his way to third he'll hold up there and
buxton has another extra base hit the
infield is midway with three infielders
on the right side heel one swing the
ball lifted in the air to short center
white back on it now in he positions
himself behind it makes the catch fires
to the plate arise tags at third but
goes back on the shallow fly ball he's
unable to advance well we saw nelson
cruz head down the tunnel with michael
salazar after his strikeout in the third
inning and there is a change it'll be
miguel cino hitting in the d.h spot got
word that nelson cruz left the game
after his
third inning at bat with neck tightness
so no swings and caps went up the first
base side it starts foul but the funky
spin moves at fair low plays it touches
the base and that ends the inning a
one-out double for the twin second
baseman brings up max kempler
this one on the ground third base
and a pump fake and a good job by holt
to make sure he gets the lead runner and
he just kind of got polanco hung out
there for the five unassisted
fielders choice two men out here in the
fifth and this one is lifted high into
the air
left side of the infield
holt is under it back pedals onto the
turf and makes the catch to get workvet
for the final out in the end and kento
maeda who's trying to regain the form he
had in 2020.
he had a swing and a miss boy nice
adjustment there by
trevino the catcher he swung at three
sliders
outside out of the zone strike one two
and three and here's connor falefa who
was one for two
batter and this ball is well stroked
into center field buxton
in front of the horny track except plays
big in the three up three down inning
for kenta maeda he's completed five
level we go to the bottom of the sixth
hit
miata just needed seven pitches
to get through the fifth inning and he
gets the first out of the sixth on his
first delivery one away doulas garcia
he's d.h and normally center fielder for
his ranger ball club two-two pitch he's
lifted into the air deep right center
field kepler going back he's looking up
and this one is gone it's an opposite
field home run for adolesce garcia and
the rangers were on the board here at
4-1 he had worked him away another
slider but that one's a pretty good one
down and away but garcia had seen it
enough times this afternoon that is a
big home run into that rangers bullpen
and now gallup gallow has been on twice
today swing and there's a ball hit way
out of this ballpark how far will it go
how about the facade of the second level
in right field joey gallo
with a topper to make it 4-2 holy smokes
that thing was blasted these huge bombs
that joey gallo has in that bag
everybody knew this was gone including
joey gallo for two twins max kepler is
going to come up here this inning
our ground ball to first high hop off
the base what a play by low to grab it
and go to the base and retire kepler for
the first out of the inning that is not
an easy play certainly is not and an
excellent job by nate lowe so nate lowe
slices one out into left center and that
will bring the tie run to the plate in
the person of adolesce garcia you
mentioned alkalo's given up seven home
runs most recent was to this guy swung
on tap left side of the diamond arise
has it across the diamond the throw is
in time for out number one low scoots to
second it's a 5-3 put out now joey gallo
pitch swung on a missed he struck him
out
98 up and out of the zone bottom of the
ninth robles will try to protect a 4-2
lead and the rangers are down to their
last out
four wins in a row for the twins and a
three-game sweep in texas